art i don't want to alarm you dick is
talking about isakai again
in the beginning
there was darkness and then god said
boom
let there be light so he created sword
art online this happened in the
prehistoric era of 2012. by now we all
know the origin story of the modern
isekai genre and how it's come to
saturate the anime market it's been
almost a decade a decade since the
initial isokai boom so you think after
all this time audiences would finally
start to get bored and yet somehow we
don't seem to be getting less we seem to
be getting more so that begs the
question if you're not watching isakai
and you're not watching isekai and
you're not watching isakai then who's
watching all the isa guy it's me i
watched a lot of visa guy last year and
i know i've played my part in giving the
genre the image that it has but i
honestly think that the genre might be
on the path to a brighter future
don't mind me just taking my daily dose
of copium i think 2021 was one of the
strongest years for isakai for like
possibly the history of isekai and like
i thought we all agreed that the genre
was already stale like five years ago so
today i thought i'd break down just
what's going on with isekai today why i
think it's here to stay and the number
one thing i still absolutely hate about
the genre spoiler alert it's not what
you think it is yeah that was enough
clickbait in that intro right but before
we get to that a quick word from our
sponsor hey there do you like awesome
stuff of course you do you watch isakai
every one of us needs more awesome stuff
well thankfully today's episode is
sponsored by bespoke post bespoke post
is a monthly membership club delivering
awesome boxes of top shelf good from
under the radar brands that's free to
join they do a bunch of different boxes
from outdoor gear bar wear kitchen goods
clothing and so many other cool stuff if
you're looking for a new casual hobby or
just something new to dip your toes into
then this is the perfect service for you
like just look at the stuff they sent me
from the terror box i got an absolute
giga chad knife
i can't wait to use this next time we go
camping or outdoors from their smoked
box we got the smoked cocktail infusion
kit and i already know i'm gonna have a
lot of fun making cocktails with these
but my absolute favorite thing they've
sent me this month is this weekender bag
which is just the perfect casual bag to
pack up all your essential items you
need for a weekend trip which is no joke
actually perfect for me because i'm
literally about to go on a trip so i'm
going to be using this almost
immediately it really couldn't have come
at a bedtime and yeah i'm already packed
and ready to go every box has around 70
in retail value but only costs 49 and
the best thing is everything is
customizable you can take a quiz to
choose the title products that would
suit you and every month you'll get a
preview of the box and if you don't like
what you see you can just swap it for a
different box or just skip the month
entirely free of charge yes you only pay
for what you want so what are you
waiting for click the link in the
description and enter code giggot20 at
checkout for 20 off your first box or
you can just go to
bespokepost.com20 thank you to bespoke
post for sponsoring this video alright
weebs back to risakai i swear to god
this isn't stockholm syndrome the video
alright it's no secret that isakai
doesn't really have the best reputation
among anime fans and i absolutely see
why the same bland overpowered
protagonist being transported or
reincarnated or summoned to that same
rpg world with the same harem living the
same self-insert power fantasy the
easyguy genre definitely went through an
extended phase where we got
some [ __ ]
like
a lot of [ __ ]
like
oh stinky
poo poopy
i really still shouldn't find as funny
sure there were outliers that stood out
but a lot of us got bored of the scene
very very very quickly and if you ever
wondered why it was ever like this then
you have one place to blame sure setsuni
nado this is a site where users can post
their own web novels for others to read
kind of like the youtube of light novels
re zero slime summer spider overlord
mashoka tensei shield hero konosuba if
there's an isa guy big or small that's
come out in the last 10 years it's
probably come from here so when i'm
talking about modern isekai what i'm
really referring to is not okay or
stories that have come from this one
site and if you look at the stories that
have been adapted from here you'll
basically see how much it's had an
effect on the modern isekai culture if
you've ever wondered why a lot of modern
light level adaptations feel so [ __ ]
homogenous isakai or not it's probably
because the source material originated
from here and if i'm allowed to put my
tinfoil hat on for a moment and
speculate based on other sites with
user-generated content all of this kind
of makes sense remember when casey
neistat started posting and then every
youtuber vlog needed to be a casey
neistat style video or when mr beast
blew up and then everyone to this day is
still trying to market their videos like
a cheap copy of mr beast well imagine
the same kind of influence between
creators being permeated through an
entire generation of web novel authors
on a single site and suddenly you
understand why a lot of isakayan fantasy
stories feel like they are copying from
each other why do like novel titles
sound so [ __ ] dumb what because they
are literally clickbait to get users to
click on their story like you see with
youtube videos except imagine if our
youtube videos get turned into
professionally published works and
you're stuck with titles like i got
addicted to v tubers and regret
everything honestly it's not about title
for a light novel content creators will
naturally gravitate towards the type of
content they see doing well no matter
what platform they're on it's something
we see with any site youtube tick tock
twitch does that excuse the amount of
mediocrity that's come from there no but
it does give a bit of an insight into
why so many isakai were made and sets
the stage for the state of the genre
today recently it really feels like the
isekai anime being adapted has finally
started to find its own footing and
we're moving past the point where shows
were defined by a single cheap gimmick
well we're in another world except this
guy has a smartphone and this guy is a
mum and this guy is a vibrator instead
more often i think we're seeing actual
interesting concepts they get explored
in more depth like people are starting
to realize that audiences want more than
just the same power fantasy show with
some dumb [ __ ] gimmick slime season 2
took its premise and then fully leaned
into becoming a civilization type city
builder where rimaru actually encounters
problems he can't just solve with force
makes hard decisions makes mistakes and
then fully suffers the consequence of it
the world's finest assassin said let's
isekai john wick if you take someone
who's already skilled and powerful in
the real world how would he use his
skills and knowledge to break the
systems presented in the fantasy world
what happens when a goddess isekai is
more than one person to get the job done
what will the majority of people do
realist hiro takes a really interesting
look at what happens if we take modern
psychology and apply it to governing a
medieval fantasy setting
machiavellianism game theory eventually
in the manga it gets to the point where
we're using examples from the cold war
capitalism fighting communism the main
character takes lessons we've learned
from our own history and applies what
has historically worked for us in
another world these are just some of the
interesting ideas i came across with the
shows this year and many of them aside
from the basic premise and setting
explored totally different subjects and
ideas like now just because you see
several isekai airing in a single season
that's no indicator that the shows will
actually have anything in common with
each other mushoka tensei re zero my
next life is a villainess sentence of a
bookworm restaurant in another world
these are all easter guys set in your
traditional fantasy world that are
completely independent of each other in
plot tone characters and appeal i've
been killing slimes for 300 years has
more in common with dragon maid than it
does with the other isekai with slime in
the title is there still a lot of
garbage being made yes but it's no
longer as relevant to look at a new show
and say it's not like your typical
yisokai because a lot of isekai are no
longer like your typical isekai i don't
know if this is sounding like massive
isocyclium right now so i just want to
go in a little tangent to look at what i
think might be a similar case that
happened for gaming the shooter genre i
remember when these first exploded onto
the scene and you couldn't get away from
them halo revolutionized console
shooters setting the blueprint that many
modern shooters still use to this day
halo 2 set the stage for online gaming
only for call of duty 4 to skyrocket
shooters into the mainstream and from
there on there was no turning back your
friends started playing shooters your
brothers and sisters and your cousins
started playing shooters heck i think i
even caught a glimpse of your grandma
playing search and destroy on terminal
once shooters were absolutely
inescapable and there was a point where
i swear every big game released was a
shooter or had some kind of [ __ ]
shooter mechanics in it shooter after
shooter after shooter after shooter it
was like we were getting the same copy
and paste game from every big company
trying to cash in on a quick buck
oversaturation was a real thing and
gamers were getting visibly fatigued by
them all so 20 years later what do we
have to show for it
well halo's got a grapple hook now as
tired as we got of shooters they never
really went anywhere but instead carved
out its own corner in the industry that
is still consistent to this day did we
get another card 4 or halo combat
evolved no but what we did get were
small tweaks and innovations that slowly
meant that different shooters could find
their own niche you want something more
on a grand scale of battles with
vehicles well go play battlefield want
something more team based and tactical
well counter-strike and rainbow six is a
thing colorful abilities how about
overwatch battle royale 2 well good
thing apex exists oh you just want to
see your childhood ruined
well
there's still fortnight i don't know why
itachi gets so much flack from murdering
the uchiha clan where sasuke right here
is quite clearly murdering their entire
legacy the term shooter in the first
place is such a broad term for a game
where you point at something then click
a button for that object to commit die
and i think this could be what isakai is
turning into for anime izukai could just
become a staple of anime the same way
that high school is there are hundreds
if not thousands of anime shows set in
high school but that doesn't mean that
any two shows are gonna have anything in
common with each other if anything i
just wish these shows put in a little
bit more effort to at least look more
distinct you look at some genres in
anime you're like damn all of these have
such distinct style and feeling to them
and then you look at each guy and you're
like
they're the same picture it's like every
show is still using the same two
character designers with the same
[ __ ] color palette that just melds
into one conglomeration of generic mess
that makes it impossible to discern any
of these shows at just a glance but you
know what baby steps at this point is
just comfort food for me sometimes it is
still the same copy and paste show yes
there is still a lot of trash out there
but more often now you'll find these
neat little ideas packaged into the same
familiar formula you've seen that will
make you take a step back and think huh
that was actually pretty damn fun i'm
not saying isaika has suddenly turned
over a new leaf but what i'm saying is
in 2021 it didn't feel as cheap anymore
and there was more variety than ever for
a genre that is apparently all the same
i do think it still has one massive
problem but it's just not the one
everyone seems to complain about because
to me the one biggest thing i wish would
change is that
there needs to be an isekai that has an
ending in almost a decade of the genre i
don't think i've seen a single one come
to a conclusion and it's kind of getting
to me pretty much the only ones i could
think of are shows that came before the
modern boom all of them even the
so-called good ones don't feel like
they've gotten anywhere close to being
finished no game no life more like no
season 2 no more overlord yeah overlord
of half a [ __ ] kingdom rising of the
shield hero yeah this is more like the
slight incline of the shield hero
re-zero more like
zero chance of ever seeing this end okay
that was awful my problem with modern
isekai isn't that they are bad it's that
they're so damn disposable we start with
one easy guy have a bit of fun and then
just move on to the next one and then
forget about all of them it feels like a
lot of the times writers come in with a
single interesting idea explore it and
then have no idea where to go so the
readers lose interest or the writer just
stops i've seen so many heroes
journeying to take on a demon lord and
not a single one has ever reached his
doorstep that doesn't feel like there's
anything close to a complete story and
instead of focusing on finishing one it
feels like the focus for anime is making
six more and because of this nothing has
any staying power we don't see any
stories reach their maturity and because
of this it becomes so vapid mushoka
tensei re-zero overlord it's series like
these where you can see the foundations
being laid for a full blown tale there
is depth there is characters there's a
thought out world behind it it feels
like these shows are actually trying to
tell a full story rather than coming in
with a few interesting ideas and [ __ ]
off re-zero just spent an entire [ __ ]
season in one place so they could say
hey let's have subaru stop dying so
cheaply let's make amelia an actual
character and while a lot of people may
have found the slower progression boring
i respect the fact that i had the
confidence to spend the time to really
flesh out sides of these characters we
never got to see in season one and
mushoka tensei is well you already know
how i feel about mashogi tensei if there
was a show that could lead the charge
for all the changes i wanted to see this
could be it because unlike most other
isakai the source material is already
done yes it has a [ __ ] ending that's
why i hope to god that these types shows
will get the chance to fully follow
through with the story they want to tell
like your attack on titans my hero
academias and demon slaves they get the
seasons all the seasons they rightfully
deserve because i don't feel like we're
even close to reaching the peaks these
stories could tell and i think it's only
when we do get the chance to see some of
these peaks that isekai can start being
taken more seriously i think this is the
one thing single-handedly stopping
izakaya from eating at the big boys
table where we don't have to feel like
pointing at these shows we like and say
no guys this is a good show for anisakai
and instead just saying no guys this is
just a good show in conclusion isakai
will never die
it just gets reincarnated into
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too alpha
sigma basil dysfunctional degenerates
elephant aivito jeff levardos manopla
payne patchett pony stark walter and
everyone else my patreon for helping to
support me this month and making this
video possible okay guys that was it
that was my yearly easy card video i
know you're bored of me talking about
isakai but sometimes i just need to get
out of my system okay i just need to
talk about izakaya every once in a while
okay you know that you know that by now
right i really hope this doesn't become
a poorly aged thing and uh isikai ends
up sucking in 2022. so touchwood that is
going to continue being good through
2022 and beyond but if you want to see a
more concrete opinion on every isikai i
watched in 2021 and some of them that i
also even didn't end up watching then i
recently made a tier list on every
single isakai and fantasy show that came
out in 2021 and you can check that out
on my second channel right now yes if
you didn't know i have a second channel
so god forbid if you want to hear about
me talking about isakai even [ __ ]
more uh you can check out the link in
the description i'll put the link to the
video there anyway though that's it from
me today i won't keep you here too long
i've been giggup and i will see you all
next time